are you following any of these stories
with russia ukraine you following any of
that how could you not okay
unfortunately so what what do you think
about i mean you said you you had a
skype call one time you said you would i
had a skype call a few years ago with
putin and i i got to know putin
indirectly because
his
the lady who runs
the uh embassy in new york they eat at
nellos all the time and her son and i
his son wanted me to baptize him
actually and then somebody who's son
her son her son yeah and she runs that
so that's how i got to know them and
then all the russian diplomats because
of the united nations meet three or four
times a year in new york they were
always in nello's i live one block away
from knowles on madison avenue so i was
there every day it was like my lunch
room
and
we got to talking about vodka and i used
to drink my vodka in ellos my wine all
that stuff that i produce
and he's a big godfather fan putin is
so she brought a bottle to him
when the plane went back
they gave him a bottle
so
they were talking he he drank beluga
black at that time i don't know what he
drinks now and we made a bet so that's
what i know about him the other thing i
know about him is that when steven
seagal was in trouble
with warrants
for
and and jules nasa was a very close
friend of mine who produced everything
with him
they got they had to get you know cigal
out of the country out because he had uh
we didn't know
he attacked young girls
in the south
and they were looking for them
fathers were
so
putin
took him in
like he did snowden
they are living in siberia now
they have no documentation no who knows
now what's going on
but
after putin was done with them doing
this karate
that was it but they're over there
that's what i know about them that's all
i know about them really but i don't i
don't know now you know as we all knew
he was supposed to be the richest man in
the world something like 611 billion
dollars
so he deflated his own currency
yeah you're talking about 40 of it right
dropped in the last eight days
and now he's going out there wanting to
uh
uh see 60 trillion
rubles from citizens if sanctions are
tightened i mean that's a pretty crazy
story right there to say seize
60 trillion rubles if sanctions are
tightened who does that pressure go on
the most
is that on so here's the story of
pinball february 28th in response to the
measures have taken abroad
state duama deputy from communist party
of the russian federation nikola arafi
has revealed funds placed by russian
residents will be utilized in the event
of a fresh economic collapse if they
block all the funds they are brought
then the government will have no choice
but to seize all the deposits of the
population there are about 60 trillion
rubles in order to get out of the
situation in terms of gold and foreign
currency russia now possesses around 640
billion dollars in reserves outside of
the nation apart from that 14 trillion
rubles which is 158 billion dollars and
another 470 billion in oligarchs wealth
are held in foreign banks
i mean this you get to this point it's a
level of desperation for you to go out
there and say hey 60 trillion dollars
from everybody wow being taken back what
do you think about that it's
it's becoming
increasingly obvious putin is basically
trying to make the ussr great again
you know he's he's basically
trying to sure up the eastern bloc
whatever's happening in ukraine he's
i mean talking about taking but he
created it it's interesting he's trying
to shore up but he's created the
self-fulfilling prophecy with putin i
mean he's xkgb he i mean
look when you hear that the government
and the communist party
of the russian federation
is planning on
taking money from the people trillions
of dollars
what does this sound like i mean the
whole time the same thing biden's trying
to do
but the whole the whole premise of
communism is that the government
controls the wealth and the industry and
the capital right right the whole
premise of capitalism is that
you know individuals have the power to
do what they want with their money this
is
this is actually if you're russia that's
an issue of communism that's what
they're doing this is very scary is it
not
when you talk about putin trying to take
people's wealth well but that that's
what that's what that philosophy is
accustomed to so that's right you you
say
if they tighten sanctions i have to take
the rubles from
citizens so right now they're shutting
down
uh major networks people are walking off
yeah yeah they're just shutting down
they're like listen we're not doing
because you can't
15 years of imprisonment if you tell
what's really going on and you call out
the government so
the media imagine living in russia right
now i don't live in russia so i don't
know what's going on over there but i
would say the media that's controlled
nationalized media
they're defending whatever positions
he's got because if you don't you are
fired right you're not going to be able
to be on air and one phone call is going
to say you're out you've got 15 years
besides but who who are the enemies
right like what is who is the russian tv
selling as the enemy russian tv is
saying all these sanctions look how much
they're hurting you to the point that we
have to take that money from you we're
not doing it they're doing it
they're the reason for it and you know
as crazy as it sounds a lot of people
believe that
there's a lot of they're betting spoon
fed that information how they know
anything otherwise the same thing is
going on here in america as well people
are being spoon-fed here's what i will
say to you that we don't know okay
here's what we don't know how many
different stories have you and i
followed
where at first we emotionally oh and
then later on like oh my god like okay
give me let's go through a list of them
911 weapons of mass destruction you know
you go to saddam hussein you know okay
you go to uh blm and later on you find
out the ladies being funded and you're
buying these houses you go through
russia oh my god oh russia is this and
all what this durham dossier hillary
clinton how many so
one of the hardest things for us to do
right now it's very difficult because as
a person that's
watching this stuff you don't really
know what's going on behind closed doors
it started off don't forget the start
off a couple months ago with biden
saying russia is going to attack you and
ukrainian president saying stop saying
this you're scaring people they're not
going to do it and it's like well they
put 175 000 people on your border what
do you mean they're not going to attack
you well no nothing's going to have they
put a hospital there they put a blood
bank there they're getting ready to
attack you they're not gonna attack us
then they go try to get the airport
eventually they get the airport back
and then now
you know the next concern is is this
gonna lead to a
nuclear war or not then you look at some
of the countries how they're behaving uh
uh russia's foreign minister you heard
what russia's foreign minister yesterday
said did you hear not russia's china's
foreign minister what they said
yesterday
china's foreign minister yesterday said
vladimir putin is our most important
ally
vladimir putin is our most important
ally yeah this is
foreign most important strategic partner
let me say the word better he's our most
important strategic partner china's
foreign minister said that yesterday
why are they saying that so
look at iran look at venezuela look at
china look at india look at u.s each is
playing a role right now okay what role
are they playing so biden just said
right now we're gonna stop all the oil
coming from russia but biden's camp just
had a meeting with
uh uh maduro to to potentially go get
oil from there
and now they're having a conversation
with iran which one of those three
countries loves america iran doesn't
love america venezuela doesn't love
america why are we doing dealings with
the enemy
but we can do it in-house but we don't
want to do it in-house why i don't want
to do peter ducey was yesterday pushing
saki
on why aren't we doing it ourselves and
she snapped and she got upset and it's
like we can do it ourselves we just
opened the box
we got a hundred and 100 years of
reserve
right now and you got folks that are
going to the gas station
saying i can't pay 535
i can't pay 5.45 well you won't give it
to trump that's all that's about well so
then india check this out what india
just did here's what's interesting about
india india avoids uh condemning putin
to get weapons for china fight
what this is a bloomberg story china
fight what do you mean china fight so
obviously we know india and china are
not allies
but we know china and russia are top
allies strategic partners quote unquote
their relationship yeah so here's a
bloomberg story yeah quote-unquote their
relationship is rockstar india plans to
avoid condemning vladimir putin vision
of ukraine
as it needs russian weapons in its
standoff with china and officials in new
delhi are confident the us won't apply
much pressure moscow has been one of
india's biggest weapons suppliers since
the coal world with more than half of
india's fighter jets and almost all of
its tanks coming from the country russia
also
uh
backed prime minister
narendra modi
hardline policies in the disputed regime
of kashmir which were widely criticized
modi's government is also confident
washington will look
the other way on this issue as india
becomes a more important u.s partner
taking on china in the asia pacific
region the people said india is part of
so-called quad group with the u.s japan
and australia that has sought to counter
china's influence okay
but
counters so why would russia help you
then that becomes the question why would
russia help india
knowing if i help you
that's going to hurt my relationship
with china it is so complex what's going
on right now that everybody that says
whatever they say from the media i think
even the sakes of the world you have to
take everything that people are saying
and
not jump to conclusion anywhere because
the rea i don't believe anybody really
knows what the hell is going on i don't
think anybody really knows what the hell
is going on well it just comes down to
the friend of my friend is my enemy and
the enemy of my enemy is my friend not
in this case well just there's so many
today there's so many different moving
parts
you have you have india who is basically
unwilling to
talk smack or you know say anything bad
about russia because that's where
they're getting their weapons and then
china's rock-solid relationship with
russia but but india is doing everything
they can to combat china's influence and
then you have this quad australia japan
united states
india right it's the strangest thing
australia
it's just there's so many different
moving parts and now they're talking
about
if the us you know wants to because they
haven't full-on gone
putting sanctions on russia's energy
section like john mccain once famously
said russia is just a gas station
masquerading as a country because that's
their entire gdp gas oil the energy
section
now you know you have people like elon
musk basically saying america needs to
start drilling pumping for oil but we
have it well exactly so there's just
it's it's so complicated and then the
backdrop of all this the scary part like
dylan said is is there a nuclear war
happening are there so many different
moving parts
that the nuclear
people are the most scary thing i mean
as far as we know they can control if
they want to
lower the prices at the pump all they
have to do is just open the pipeline
again
it's here
we have it
the question is why are they not doing
it because
biden
biden is totally against that he closed
the day he won he closed it down so if
you enjoyed this little segment from the
podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]